used in business so this representative
was basically saying look we just need a
short-term agreement basically to say we
will not allow AI to be used
until Regulators etc etc have actually
defined what AI is Def find what AI can
be used for def find when AI cannot be
used let's actually allow government the
courts Regulators to lead the way on
this and in the meantime just don't
allow it it's only a three-year contract
in the terms of this technology that's
not a particularly long time it can be
resolved in three years time and when
hopefully the legal system Etc will have
caught up now to me that seems a very
logical way to go ahead especially be
seeing that anything they agree could be
deemed as illegal this time next year
anyway if the courts decide so so yeah